what we do first - we got a covert ops
nice choice do you think they're they're
gonna have cute dialogue with one
another since there's some history there
there is guys and a child there's that
yeah talk to me that would mean you'd
have to keep quiet
you're right never mind wait yeah there
you go all right so common specials for
Sonia she's got our energy rings back
she has an airdrop yeah there we go
that one's great because it you can do
yep he hasn't hurt this is priestly for
a couple of reasons
so this one closes distance from a farm
right and if you close and you want to
gain some distance between the two it
also goes over projectiles which is
pretty slick and the e^x does multicam
nice so you know Lakeland classic move
is bad so those are her shared common
specials and so now we'll go into the
variant yes right so in the car over
covert ops this one is really all about
pairing and countermoves
and you know to use this for this
variant it's all about like stopping
rush downs keeping the opponent like you
want them to tech names so she has this
new ability this is a girl period here
so this one encounter you know any sort
of like pleasure
so I'll get there a second she also has
one that's right I missed it Meredith
right again nope I win can we show wait
oh there's more military stands Oh
awesome
so you enter military stands and you can
do a variety of moves right off there so
you can grab opponent fancy yep you can
do a local distance I've done that one
yeah all right you do a cartwheel nice
and you can also exit out of this dance
at any time oh just cancel out that
works I'm gonna try buy the combo that I
worked on I want to see it oh man we
drove so bad Thailand's no combos here
you go
they're on you got this no all right
you've embarrassed yourself enough
moving on one more time I did it so many
times this today so let's see oh no one
was lost the street violence all right
there's a row I love this throw the
crucifix in the Plitvice whoo all right
so let's go to the next variation that's
right urghhh you want to kill me with an
x-ray mm-hmm yeah
yep go ahead give the hit because it's a
parry home yeah but I don't have meter
Oh
magically I know okay now you can ready
yep let's go March the kiss no wonder
they're do those right maybe like that
down write that down all right know
which one next Pete how about some
demolition demolition whoo let's let's
do town oh okay oh yeah I got a history
those - I'm gonna do a mystery and maybe
we can finish Cato off for cannon all
right maybe
we should probably talk now yeah you
won't escape this time
and escaped and this all have fun this
won't be fun so demolition barians cool
thing about this one is mean she's got
remain strapped to their so this
variation is all about kind of grenade
management so you know you start out
with three and you use one already so
you do have an inventory yeah and you
can see on the leg there there's two
good nights there the blue spot is where
one is right
so as you show she has kind of a great
deal and the cool thing about her
grenades she has two different types of
grenades and you can choose between she
has a stun grenade of the for aggravated
depending on your needs what do you do
they call back the drone 9x there you go
so what's really interesting about the
grenades are you can detonate them early
so you just double press the button
exactly right and if you get into a
situation where you don't have any
grenades all right so right here yep so
much pressure you right mom coming up
coming up won't you e^x the drill get
out of get drilling thanks from the
jungle so just use all my grenades I'm
driving back again yeah awesome
you can also EXO here and it will throw
the remaining grenades they can have
their so cool just drop to know and you
can
she also has a wake up attack my
favorite wake up in the game right now
so she'll throw the grenades down so
they're trying to pressure you you'll
throw the grenades out real quick as a
wake up attack that's right cool let's
go on to the next variation how they're
putting some combos it brings they're
not strong at the end yeah I want I warm
up very very slowly about 35 minutes
into it streamline I get a combo
marathon yeah it really is
so let's go to the final version Special
Forces
oh you know what we forgot to do what I
forgot to finish Kate oh yeah oh well I
guess we're gonna have to do it here you
have to kill their king yeah sorry
everybody
so there's a lot of really different
ways to play Sonya all the variations
very different on how you have seen the
utility of course yes and they're gonna
see that especially here yeah this is
one of my favorite ones so it begins
looks that way it will end soon enough
ling-ling I love this variation because
it's all about like being strategist
right so this one you can see her visual
difference here is she has armbands
Raider bands and what she does is she
can call in the drone it doesn't bring
in grenades it actually is there for you
to use kind of at your disposal kind of
an assist like right yeah so it's this
drone is tied down for how much time but
like it will go away and you have to you
know that this this variation is really
used for mix ups so there's four drone
attacks that will show real quickly -
before you show those you've actually
parked the drone that's right I can put
it down yep and that's what I loved you
Matt for you know letting it go
off-screen kind of a guy in the corner
there's like a lot of different reasons
to use like there's it can be drone your
enemy than you like Thanksgiving like
bookends up no that's cool so alright so
the first attack is the heavy glass this
is a short-range quick shot straight run
work oh there it is okay Franta air to
rush down defense the next one is the
holiness
it's at like a pulse blast it's great
for setting up rush or against guys who
like to jump around go ahead do that
right so they will track you will hold
me a person a lot of time before kind of
just gives up it just fades away right
you can definitely get in on them while
that's happening yeah the next one is
the kamikaze so she there's two
different kamikaze attacks one moment
lake is immortal horizontal like
straight up and it's a bit slow
that's low one right you have to block
it low and that way yep so you keep the
guys guessing you don't know what's
coming and what I really like to do with
this is you can have the drone out you
can do you know pretty blasted holding
this all or just kind of just keep
pressure on them right
the drone starts to blink the lights on
it blink colors or the match on the
radar band with what the door is doing
things like you know if the attacker
might attack gotcha if it's about to go
you can actually just you know kamikaze
awesome yeah it's really fun homing is
so much fun cuz then you know you do
this you start running towards no it has
so much stuff to do there are you know
it's time for let's just I have a live a
match here okay well oh okay you can
play Liu Kang did you do oh I am so good
at Liu Kang
give me my Kang Kang
I just told you not to with it
classic Lansdowne so uh we can do about
this but the game comes out a few days
ahead like even a what 12 days 12 days